bonne année oui bon bah écoutez on a
tout le mois de janvier pour souhaiter
la bonne année donc ça va en elle cette
je sais pas encore trop trop tard et ce
qui serait pas temps de faire une petite
vidéo pour parler de 2018 et de tout ce
qui s'est passé cette année
ja tout d'abord déjà vous remercier du
soutien et du fait que vous êtes de plus
en plus aujourd'hui on est 50 2000 sur
la chaîne ce qui est tout à fait énorme
je m'en rends toujours pas assez compte
des fois j'ai l'impression jeudi aéro
que jorge ait l'impression d'avoir une
chaîne de 3000 abonnés ou quelque chose
du genre mais pas du tout vous êtes
52000 et c'est beaucoup c'est beaucoup
faut le dire donc 2018 si on parle en
termes de chiffre vite fait 2018 ça a
été 36 vidéo de sorties dans l'année en
comptant bien évidemment des petites
réactions par exemple à des trailer ou
hot pas que les vidéos théorie c'est
quand même pas mal 36 vidéo c'est plus
de 18000 abonnés de gagner donc à peu
près comme j'avais gagné en 2017 ont à
peu près du j'avais un petit peu percé à
un moment et 2,8 millions de vues alors
fact un petit peu intéressant quels sont
les cinq vidéos les plus vues de la
chaîne en 2018 je précise en cinquième
position on retrouve le trois théories
sur les animaux fantastiques 2 une vidéo
qui vous a beaucoup plus que j'ai
beaucoup aimé faire et franchement je
suis assez fier parce que ça a été
vraiment une grosse vidéo je suis
content qu'elle soit dans le top 5 parce
que je m'étais donné vraiment à fond
pour être le plus complet possible et
vous avez été rendez vous et vous avez
tous été ultra bienveillant donc
vraiment merci
en quatrième position on retrouve le
trois théories sur les animaux
fantastiques mais cette fois ci la saga
vidéo qui vous a beaucoup plu j'ai
beaucoup aimé faire je suis content de
l'avoir là tant mieux pour la troisième
vidéo
normalement elle devrait être comptée
comme 2017 mais c'est une vidéo qui est
sorti le 29 décembre 2010 est donc elle
a fait tout s'est vu on va dire vraiment
début 2018
ces deux trois théories sur star wars 8e
la sto jedi qui a été vraiment une vidéo
mais phénoménal c'est une vidéo c'est la
seule vidéo qui me ottan rapporté
d'abonnés j'avais gagné environ 5000
abonnés juste avec cette vidéo ce qui
était incroyable et c'est pour ça
qu'elle n'allait dans le top 5 parce
qu'elle a fait énormément de vue en 2018
bien qu'elle soit sortie fin 2017
mais je suis fier de l'avoir là en
deuxième position c'est un regret
vraiment un regret et je pense qu'on
fera une vidéo là dessus un jour parce
que sa ferme en 430 en tête
la deuxième vidéo qu'est le plus vu sur
la chaîne à mon plus grand regret c'est
ma vidéo théorie la vérité sur ce look
est sorti début 2018 début milieu 2018
c'est une vidéo je regrette vraiment
parce que je me suis mal pris je les
fais un peu la va-vite le titre est
vraiment pu ta clique je trouve
bref cette vidéo il ya rien qui va je
fais des fautes de français je ne
maîtrise pas le truc de star wars
vraiment l'univers étendu etc
c'est vraiment une vidéo je regrette et
je peux en métal et sut très longtemps
mais c'est une vidéo où je regrette
vraiment et je pense qu'on ferait une
vidéo là dessus sur les théories que je
regrette un truc genre ça peut être
sympa
donc voilà elle est quand même deuxième
ça fait plaisir merci mais j'aurais aimé
que ce soit d'autres vidéos et la
première vidéo alors pour moi c'est
incroyable parce que j'ai jamais autant
fait de vue sur une seule vidéo et
j'en reviens toujours pas aujourd'hui
c'est le plan de doctor strange la vidéo
théorie sur le plan doctor strange café
500000 vu quasiment c'est incroyable
merci vraiment et je suis très content
que cette vidéo sa sortie à ce que je
m'étais celle là aussi je m'étais
vraiment donner à fond pour être dans
les temps pour elle le plus complet etc
ça fait plaisir ça là ça fait vraiment
plaisir mais 2018 a été aussi une année
un petit peu de rencontres
je suis quelqu'un d'assez solitaire j'ai
toujours fais ma petite chaîne youtube
dans mon coin
mais grâce à dj jean louis j'ai pu faire
des rencontres ce que j'ai dit a défait
sa vidéo toute fin 2017 je crois que
c'était novembre 2017
oui partageait 10 chaînes de théorie et
avec la plupart en fait on a pris
contact et on est encore amis et
certains même des meilleurs potes des
vrais gros tu vois mon pote la liesse
donc évidemment tu es super ça m'ouvre à
faire des collages etc
on va reparler pour 2019 mais j'ai pu
rencontrer et de leighton
les mauves théorie shivan à la cathine
borne à katyn c'était un autre contexte
mais et puis même didier shandwick et
ultra sympa et j'aimerais bien habiter
un jour on en reparlera etc
et c'est tout
oui bon ben ça va il ya c'est vrai y
arrière-scène c'est vrai je peux pas
passer à côté d'ailleurs au self
sachant qu'on va faire encore plus dans
le futur et oui mon gros aéronefs tout
ça ça a été de belles rencontres en 2018
et je suis hyper content ça c'est un
gros point positif parce que moi qui
était un petit peu dans mon coin j'ai pu
faire de grosses rencontres et
développer ces mêmes des amitiés etc
alors après j'oublie pas d'autres
personnes que j'ai connues avant comme
miley ou kaisen et cetera mais c'est
cool on commence à se créer un petit
réseau un petit groupe de youtube heures
de vidéastes poteau je préfère donc
c'est génial je vois pas quoi dire de
plus 2018 ça a été aussi pas mal de
films et de jeux vidéo de découverte de
série pour ma part et c'est évidemment
on traite de théories sur la pop culture
donc les jeux vidéo etc
les films je vous faire mon petit hop un
petit top 3 de mes films favoris
1 pour commencer j'ai pas vu énormément
de films non plus parce que voilà je
vais pas tout le temps au cinéma etc
j'ai pas vu des centaines de films comme
certain par exemple ou autre mais
d'après ce que je donne tout ce que j'ai
vu de tout ce qui m'a marqué c'est
vraiment un petit truc subjectif c'est
pas un gros top mais voilà c'est juste
un petit truc subjectif en troisième
position je mettrai les animaux
fantastiques 2 parce que moi j'ai
vraiment apprécié je trouve qu'on est
vraiment rentré dans le vif du sujet
avec les animaux fantastiques et j'ai
vraiment bien aimé le filin grendel
valdes et dumbledore jude law et johnny
depp qui joue extrêmement bien
c'était un pur plaisir en deuxième
position je mettrais annihilation
ça a été vraiment un film qui m'a marqué
je voulais vraiment faire un trois
théories sujet je savais en plus que
trois théories ça n'est pas faire gros
sujets qu'ils allaient faire des bus etc
mais je trouvais qu'il méritait et je
kiffe les films une taille une grosse
réflexion derrière et c'est un peu à
l'inter stellar premier contact et du
coup annulation
c'était une grosse surprise et je suis
franchement ravie de ce film et quand
j'y repense encore aujourd'hui je suis
encore tout chamboulé
j'ai encore la musique en tête etc ça a
été vraiment un gros truc
et enfin je suis obligé de mettre en
première place je pense que ça va
étonner personne mais je mets une finity
war évidemment une finity voir ça a été
la consécration de marvel surtout que
marvel ça a été une de mes découvertes
personnel de 2018 parce que j'avais
beaucoup de préjugés sur les films etc
je trouvais que c'était bon c'est super
héros c'est des gentils qui gagne tout
le temps etc et l'attaquent
je regarde tous les marvel est là juste
après il ya une fille d'ivoire qui sort
bon sens la claque que sa manie j'étais
vraiment à fond ça a été incroyable et
je pense vraiment que ça va être un film
qui va rester un petit peu dans
l'histoire du cinéma
tanoh c'est même devenu un mème c'est
assez incroyable
tout le monde connaît thanos à boire
plus fin autant que dark vador ou les
grands méchants etc
ça fait vraiment plaisir c'est vraiment
le film qui m'a marqué et puis ça se
voit dans les vidéos on en a parlé
énormément d'in fi nit ivoiriens vont
encore en parler avec avengers 4 mais je
fais une petite mention spéciale à aller
à solostar warstory parce que je l'avais
vraiment bien aimé moi personnellement
malgré le petit as tu es tout seul tu
vas t'appeler en solo et puis
effectivement ready player one était
vraiment aussi un film que j'ai vraiment
kiffé bien qu'un petit peu trop à dans
les sens par moments mais j'ai vraiment
bien kiffé si je vous fais un petit top
de mes jeux
je mettrai en troisième alors j'ai pas
joué à beaucoup de jeux je suis désolé
il va pas y avoir red dead redemption va
pas y avoir ce domaine et c'est google
aux foires parce que je les ai pas fait
j'ai pas vu de les taper dessus je fais
vraiment sur ce que j'ai fait moi ce que
j'ai eu l'occasion de faire parce que je
peux pas acheter des jeux à tout va
comme ça je suis étudiant je suis dans
un mètre carré il ya encore le sommier
derrière moi mieux ranger me l'a encore
derrière moi donc comprenez moi les amis
s'il vous plaît donc je mettrais pokémon
let's go en troisième évidemment enfin
évidemment pas vraiment mais ça a été
une surprise je pensais ne pas l'acheter
à la basse a été le premier pokémon que
j'ai failli ne pas acheter alors je les
achète tous depuis que depuis diamant et
perle puisque j'ai découvert il dément
les perles à leur sortie et
au final ça a été une bonne surprise je
suis très content et je pense que ça
peut promettre pour pokémon 2010 9,6 à
améliorer évidemment alors le deuxième
est le premier j'hésite leur position
mais je vais être assez raisonnable en
deuxième je mette aux poteaux passe
traveller personnes le met dans son top
ou autres mais moi je le mets octo pas
ça a été vraiment mais mon coup de coeur
de 2018 ça a été incroyable j'ai passé
une centaine d'heures sur le jeu semble
assez tout est incroyable dans ce jeu
les une musique le contexte genre le
fait que ça soit les graphismes un peu
3d enfin du 2d rendu sur du 3d enfin
c'était vraiment le jeu magnifique
gameplay est écoulée puis une en vrai
les musiques je reviens sur la musique
mais c'était top
moi qui suis un gros gros fan de final
fantasy là ça a été vraiment ça a été un
pur plaisir nostalgique en fait de
retourner à l'époque et c'est maintenant
ça a été vraiment un gros coup de coeur
puis en premier je vais mettre super
smash bros un ultimate parce que c'est
vraiment un gros jeu et puis là c'est le
premier smash bros qui me donne vraiment
envie d'être à fond tous les jours je
suis en train de regarder les live 2 0
où je regarde des vidéos tous les jours
chez en train d'essayer m'entraîner
apprendre des techniques et tous sur
smash bros pour pouvoir peut-être vous
en proposer un stream un qui sait quand
ça a été vraiment c'est vraiment je
pense le jeu 2018 pour moi du moins du
côté nintendo c'est sûr et je fais une
petite mention spéciale vraiment avec le
coeur adèle tard une même si c'est pas
vraiment un jeu mais juste le chapitre 1
toby fox sait c'est incroyable del
termine c'est vraiment par une claque
la bande son elle est géniale autant que
celle d'anne dorte l histoire pareille
et ça va être le sujet un peu mon sujet
fétiche de théories en 2019 le pense
ça va être dur de créer ma place mais
j'espère que ça va vous plaire ça
devrait sortir fin janvier bon on parle
de 2018 ont fait que de pareilles 2018
mais on est en 2019 maintenant alors
qu'est ce que j'aimerais faire pour 2009
quelles sont mes projets qu'est ce que
je prévois qu'est ce que j'attends eh
ben on va voir ça tout de suite
déjà j'aimerais être beaucoup plus actif
dans le sens où je suis étudiant et en
plus faut que j'aie un stage etc
techniquement j'ai pas beaucoup de temps
libre on va dire il ya toujours des
trucs à faire surtout je me gère tous
les faux entretenir l'appartement gérer
des papiers des trucs comme ça les trucs
du quotidien j'arrive pas à trouver un
bon équilibre et surtout le fait que je
vais arriver à la fin de mes études
cette année en juillet donc ça va me
laisser un petit peu de temps pour bien
me consacrer et j'en veux plus me
consacrer donc avoir beaucoup plus
d'activités jeux qui ferait vraiment
j'aimerais également faire plus
d'ouverture sur les sujets la première
partie de ma chaîne si on peut pas dire
ça comme ça ça a été beaucoup de star
wars du star wars au point que je m'en
suis là c'est star wars en vous avez
bien vu j'en parle plus je repars la red
star wars neuf mais je ne compte pas
faire plus ensuite on a beaucoup parlé
de marvel et c'est bien que je me suis
déjà beaucoup ouverts j'aimerais ouvrir
encore plus je découvre des oeuvres tous
les jours genre s'est découvert walking
dead games of thrones c'était 2017 mais
on a déjà parlé m'avoir parlé undertake
undertake c'est le coeur là qui parlera
t elle c'est incroyable et plein
d'autres sujets que j'aimerais parler
donc être beaucoup plus ouvert sur les
trois théories et les autres vidéos
j'en ai beaucoup parlé avec aero on
aimerait beaucoup aussi faim mois déjà
personnellement mais je sais que lui
aussi on va faire pas mal là dessus
c'est faire des vidéos or théorie des
concepts un petit peu marrant un petit
peu divertissant en webcam
avec la faye scam je dire où en gros on
garderait les mêmes thèmes les théories
et cetera mais un petit peu de
divertissement un petit peu on est à 2
en fait ce cas mon rigole on fait des
trucs on fait des trucs cool tu vois
genre tout en restant dans la théorie et
c'est sur la pop culture
c'est un truc qui nous plairait vraiment
de ouf de faire plus de vidéos on se
montre et où on rigole on prend du bon
temps et c'est moi c'est vraiment
quelque chose que je veux faire
absolument en 2019 et j'ai déjà quelques
idées en j'en ai parlé quaero par
exemple je l'invite et on choque par
exemple les pires théorie qui existe sur
zelda ou marvel par exemple et on se les
partagent on dit qu'ils à la pure
théorie qui a trouvé la pierre théorie à
brest ça peut être des concepts marrant
comme ça ça peut être cool ça change un
petit peu du ton sérieux des vidéos 3t
aurait etc
je pense vraiment que ça peut être
également j'aimerais faire beaucoup plus
de streaming avec un emploi du temps ce
serait vraiment un truc que je kifferais
faire parce que j'ai le matos j'ai la
connexion mais je ne fais rien alors ça
a été toujours un rêve et un kiff de
faire du streaming mais il faut que la
communauté suit derrière et je vais
essayer de me donner à fond alors ce
sera sur twitch du jeu vidéo tout en
faisant des petits lacs des fois sur
youtube
mais ça serait sur tweets ch donc des
live sur league of legends sur ultimate
sur pokémon les 2 go par exemple du
chaigne hunting sur d'autres jeux tout
simplement du speed run j'étais un
speedrun heures de crash bandicoot mois
plein de choses comme ça et genre par
exemple tous les lundis et jeudis ou des
trucs comme ça et je sache je veux je
veux vraiment le faire aussi faire plus
de stream en 2019 et je vais me donner à
fond pour je veux vraiment réussir cette
année
à faire vraiment des choses encore mieux
que 2018 et enfin bon allez petit bonus
parce que voilà j'aimerais faire
beaucoup plus de collabo et ça ça va se
faire avec l layton sur pokémon par
exemple avec des mauves théorie quand il
y aura la game of thrones saison 8
aéro bon compte plus le nombre de
collègues qu'on a fait ensemble là on
est un petit peu comme le ying et le
yang et on va dire ou melide importe etc
mais il ya aussi voilà il ya deux
youtuber que j'adore vraiment et avec
qui j'aimerais faire vraiment une collab
pas sur leur chaîne jours en mode je
veux gagner des abonnés sur leur chez
nous tu mets genre les invités sur la
mienne et qu'il fasse une vidéo théorie
avec moi mais c'est ce serait vraiment
un kiff totale parce que j'y pense
depuis hyper longtemps et j'ose pas ce
serait dj shadow dream
évidemment nous a partagé et puis j'ai
eu l'occasion de parler avec lui
quelques fois rarement mais quelquefois
je kifferais l'invité sur une vidéo et
il ya un autre tube heures aussi que je
kiffe ces iconoclastes et lui aussi
j'aimerais vraiment l'invité sur la
chaîne mais j'ose pas jose vraiment pas
mais ce serait vraiment de youtube
heures que je kifferais invités juste
comme ça ils viennent ils font une vidéo
théorie avec moi jour juste ils disent
leur texte etc
enfin ça serait vraiment un kiff total
enfin voilà écoutez je ne pense pas
avoir beaucoup plus à dire pour 2019 je
vais vraiment tenté de faire un max pour
voilà pour que ce rêve continue de
s'améliorer de s'agrandir t'es pas les
100 mille abonnés cette année ce serait
où fait mais je n'y crois pas déjà si on
atteint vraiment je pense le max on
pourrait atteindre ce serait 80 milles
enfin fin décembre ou en 2020 je pense
80000 ça peut être déjà énormément
si on y réussit évidemment écoutez je
vous retient pas plus longtemps j'espère
cette vidéo n'a pas été trop longue et
que vous aurez apprécié ma compagnie je
vous souhaite vraiment de réussir un
maximum vos projets dites moi ce que
vous attendez vous pour 2019 ce soit des
idées de vidéos des projets d peu
importe
dites moi c'est important parce que je
pourrai le faire vraiment je tiens
compte de vos avis et puis bah écoute et
que le rail alors soit avec vous c'était
argot rock
allez ciao tout le monde et que 2019
soit une réussite
[Musique]